What a what the prophet would
say for the occasion of eating,
for the occasion of drinking.
He says, the prophet when he
would go to eat, he would say
bismillah. The narrations,
regarding saying bismillah all
of them mention bismillah just
that. Some scholars such
as Sheikh Al Islam, Ib Allah,
he mentions bismillah Rahim.
Both are acceptable but
bismillah is what the
narrations mention. The prophet
not only would always say
bismillah when he would go to
eat. But he is well commanded
others to say bismillah when
they eat. and if he was made to
forget, if he'd forget to say
bismillah and realize while he
was eating, he would say,
bismillah, which literally
translates to bismillah in the
beginning of this food and at
the end of it.
Then mentions that the scholars
differ on whether or not a test
me as saying bismillah or the
occasion of eating or drinking
if it is something that is
obligatory or merely
preferable. The correct opinion
he says is that it is
obligatory for a person to say
bismillah when they go to eat.
And a person who fails
purposely to say bismillah or
otherwise When they go to eat a
Shaitan will accompany them in
their food and drink. He says,
the narrations regarding its
obligatory nature, the the
obligation of saying bismillah.
They are clear and they are
authentic narrations.
Then, he goes into the issue of
if saying bismillah, if a group
of people are eating together
is it enough for one person in
that group to say bismillah or
does each person individually
have to say bismillah? It's a
difference of opinion amongst
the scholars. The opinion that
Ibn ul Kaim leans towards here
and adopts in Zad il Maad. Is
that it is an obligation on the
individual level. Each
individual is obliged to say
bismillah is obligated to say
bismillah when they go to eat.
because there are some things
Islam.
If a Wafurut, Ayan, Amarekun,
[Silence]
needs to say. It's a difference
of opinion amongst the
scholars. The opinion that Ibn
il Kaim bolsters here and
adopts here in Zad al Maed is
that it is an obligation upon
each individual. He mentions,
for example, a narration,
That's the messenger of Allah
Sallallahu Alaihi Wa Sallam was
amongst his companions. They
were eating. And a man came in
to join them. And when he came
in to join them the food was
gone very quickly. and the
prophet noticed that the food
was insufficient for all of
them and he said to the
companions, he said, if he had
said bismillah, the food would
have been enough. Ibn ol Kaim
says, clearly the companions
were eating here with the
prophet it's clear that they
had said bismillah. But this
man came in and in spite of
that, it did not suffice them.
Right? So this is an evidence
that individually, each one is
responsible for saying
bismillah. There are other
issues as well. Is something
obligatory upon every single
person? Or is something
obligatory upon? The group as a
whole, Right? This is what's
called the with the they refer
to this as and they say means
that it is an obligation. It's
binding upon each individual.
It's a binding upon the people
at an individual level. Like
salah for instance. Salah, each
person has to pray for himself.
No person can pray on behalf of
another. This is an individual
obligation. A collective
obligation is a then. One
person amongst us makes a damn.
The rest of us don't have to
make a then. Right?
He mentions for instance, a
Salem replying to a Salem.
He mentions a salam. If a
person comes in, approaches a
group of people. And conveys a
to them. Do they all have to
each individually respond or
just one person amongst them?
One person amongst them is
enough. contrary to responding
to someone who sneezes. It's
called someone who sneezes and
says the prophet says it is an
obligation upon each individual
who heard him sneeze and say to
say
but there are other issues as
well.
such as reciting
if we have an imam Do we need
to recite
even though the imam recited it
for us or not.
Imam
[Silence]
hope. We mention for instance
bismillah when we go to eat is
an individual responsibility We
mentioned as well saying to
someone who sneezes, that this
is also an individual
responsibility We mention is a
collective responsibility.
Meaning, if one person says
that's enough. For the, for the
group.
Another issue that goes along
these lines is in salah. When
we're making together, all of
us collectively is it
obligatory for each one of us
to to recite or is the imam's
recitation enough? This is a
difference of opinion amongst
the scholars and it's a very
ancient difference of opinion.
This is an issue that has been
discussed and absolutely
thoroughly gone through with in
in in at nauseam detail, right?
The opinions vary. Some of the
scholars say, each individual
person needs to recite on his
own. Whether he can hear the
imam's recitation or not. and
this is a strong opinion and
it's the opinion of
and his Another opinion is it
is only a responsibility of the
imam. The person who's praying
behind the imam has no
responsibility to recite at
all. However, a third opinion
which is the opinion of Sheikh
Al Islam, Ibn Kathir as well,
and others and it's the opinion
of the majority Also, Al Imam
Ahmed, Imam Malik Rahima Allah.
is that if the imam recites
aloud then his recitation is
sufficient. However, if the
imam recites in a silent
prayer, A then, each individual
is responsible to recite for
himself.
[Silence]
A
each two. This is important.
The reason for this, the
prophet commands us. He says,
we are not to drink all at
once. Rather, we are to drink
and divide our drinking into
reasonable gulps. He says, it
is healthier, It is more tasty,
It is cleaner, and better, and
more dignified for a person to
drink in that manner. If it is
a little bit, a person may
drink it in one, one shot.
Maybe two, maybe three, maybe
four. The point is, is that it
doesn't have to be exactly
three and a many people, they
drink the three because they've
heard of the narration, which
is a problem. Because sometimes
we hear about narrations, but
we didn't hear the whole story,
right? So, we don't have the
whole picture. We just have a
portion of it and if we
research innovation,
innovation, a lot of it comes
from having a portion of the
information rather than all of
it.
We've heard that a person
shouldn't drink all at once,
that we should divide it into
three, and so the drinking
turns into this kind of
jittering, the point is that a
person take, and take a breath,
then take another drink, let a
person do it, slowly,
methodically, dignified. This
is the point.
and when a person is completed,
completed drinking, that he is
to thank Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala and to say whether it's
eating or drinking.
Alhamdulillah. Allah the
[Silence]
someone else says the answer is
yes. It's sufficient. and
better for a person to say
Is it sufficient for a person
who mentions the prophet more
than once in a thought. Does he
have to say at each point or at
the end to suffice the whole,
what's better is at each point
and that's what the did. When
we read the books of Hadith, we
find that they would write at
each place. However it is
sufficient at one point